i'm not gonna not play um
i'm a ball player whoever picks me i'm
gonna go show up and i think we're
meeting with the bengals here in a
couple days and i'm i'm looking forward
to just talking balls seeing what
they're about seeing the offense that
they run see how they think about ball
you know the only thing that i've said
is i i just didn't want to be
presumptuous about the pick and so
that's why i've
been non-committal because i don't know
what's going to happen you know they
might not pick me they might fall in
love with someone else
so they you know you guys kind of took
that narrative and ran with it but
there was never been anything like that
from my end
sorry joe i'm skeptical joe i think
there was a plan for january
that has changed for february that's
what i think i'm sorry cincinnati
look there's a difference between the
guys submitting to the process
and wanting to play for the bengals and
the question i posed earlier in the show
shireen if you made joe burrow a free
agent and said
joe you get to pick where you want to go
do you really think the bengal's going
to be the first team he chooses no
i don't think he'll be the first team
but do you think he ends up with
cincinnati does it play for city i think
there isn't anything he can ultimately
do about it i think they have they have
kind of poked around the edges of seeing
if maybe they can scare cincinnati away
and the public effort i think they've
realized that's not going to work
because of people i'm sorry because of
people like us who will say bs we see
what's going on here we see what you're
trying to do we're going to read these
tea leaves which aren't all that
difficult to read when joe bower says
i'll play for whoever wants to pay me
then carson palmer says the bengals
aren't committed to winning then joe
burrow hires carson palmer's kid brother
to train him and then joe burrow says
i want to be the number one pick but i
want to play for a team that's committed
to winning not all that hard to figure
out which way this thing is moving
they've backed off of that now because
he ultimately has no control right he he
has to submit to the process he's not
going to sit out a whole year and give
up 36 million fully guaranteed over four
seasons in this day and age no one's
going to do that and i'll tell you this
i was at his press conference yesterday
and he looked like he was heavily
coached on his answers yesterday he had
all the right answers they were
different from a week ago in fort worth
when he was there for the davey o'brien
award and he talked about i have
leverage he backed down on that he said
well the leverage i was really talking
about was at the combine i'm not going
to work out that's not leverage he never
mentioned that
it's not leverage it's personal
preference yeah and there's no reason
for him to work out at the combine he's
going to be the number one overall pick
i mean that's not that's not a leverage
play that is a smart business move uh so
anyway i
look
i i think the bengals will end up taking
and i think he will go and he'll make
chicken salad and he may make the team
better um but but
i think it's fair to conclude based on
the signals we were getting in january
that's that there was the beginnings of
an effort to see if they could maybe get
the bengals to conclude it's in their
best interests to trade that pick to
someone else and they still met he makes
so much sense for the bengals the fact
that this is an ohio kid he won the
heisman trophy he would just generate a
lot of excitement you talk about ticket
sales he's going to sell tickets in
cincinnati which needs those ticket
sales he's going to sell a lot of
jerseys in cincinnati which needs that
he is exactly what they need but to me
they need to show a commitment to
winning this off season and they can do
that they can do that in free aids they
can do that by committing to build an
indoor practice facility there's a lot
of things they can do to say we are
committed to winning we're not the team
you think we are and the key is when it
comes to drafting joe burrow to show
that commitment to winning
it doesn't cost you any more than it
would if you draft someone else and that
that sensitivity to expense is one of
the reasons why the bengals have been
regarded as a team that isn't trying to
win that's what stunned me about the
reaction from so many bengals fans and
i'm encouraged that that many bengals
fans care it's like okay now go buy
tickets where are all of you on sundays
because there's just a sense of apathy
around the team and the reaction to this
i think fairly obvious
conclusion that maybe joe burrow doesn't
want to play for the bengals and there's
nothing he can really do about it but he
still can have a personal preference to
play elsewhere just pointing that out
for that to cause so many bengals fans
to get up in arms i i i'm encouraged
that maybe they they aren't that far
away from turning this thing around even
though they were bad enough last year to
earn the number one overall pick and
they're ready to win i mean
you know zach taylor said we wouldn't be
here if we weren't committed to winning
they want to win but this is a team that
hasn't won a playoff game since 1990.
it's been a really long time yeah i it
was the game
where
bo jackson's hip got destroyed that was
the last playoff game the bengals won in
la against the raiders before the
raiders even moved back to oakland
that's how long ago it was and uh we'll
see if the beginnings i want the bengals
to turn around cincinnati please give me
a break we got more pft live coming
right after this
except on radio
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports